Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, this week we're going
to talk about biomechanics and
the reading is Chapter 10.
I think on your syllabus it
says Chapter 10 and 13 but we're
really only going to talk about
Chapter 10 during class.
Then, our section on Thursday
will also involve two aspects of
biomechanics,
talking about materials
properties, which is what I'm
going to focus on in the lecture
today,
and thinking about some
elementary gait analysis;
gait, G-A-I-T,
or how humans walk and run and
the mechanics of that particular
kind of motion.
This is like many of the
other topics that we've covered
in the course,
a very big subject.
Some of you,
I have no doubt,
are going to go onto study
biomechanics in greater detail.
I've picked a couple of things
that I thought were interesting
to sort of teach you sort of the
elements of mechanics,
how do I use physics to think
about biological materials,
and how organisms live in a
physical world.
Today we're going to talk about
properties of biological
materials, and in particular,
two properties elasticity and
viscosity.
We'll talk about how most real
biological materials,
your skin, your brain,
the gel that makes up the
interior portion of your eye
have both of those qualities.
They're both viscous and
elastic, and they exhibit
something that we call
viscoelasticity.
By the end of the lecture
today you should a little bit
about what viscoelasticity is
and how materials that have that
property behave,
and most biological materials
have that property.
Then on Thursday we're going to
talk about locomotion:
how do animals move,
in particular how do humans
move.
We'll talk about three kinds of
motion.
The most interesting one may be
flying that humans don't do
unaided but it's interesting to
think about how flight is
possible from a mechanical
perspective.
How do organisms release
themselves from the
gravitational field and learn
how to move in flight?
We'll talk about swimming,
and we'll talk about running or
walking.
First the mechanical
properties of biological
materials and these are the two
questions that I want to focus
on during the lecture today,
and the two questions that you
should be able to answer by the
end.
What is elasticity?
How would I measure elasticity?
How would I quantify elasticity?
There might be other ways to
think about that question,
and what is viscoelasticity?
How do viscoelastic materials
differ from elastic materials?
How does that make them
different in biological--when
they're part of a biological
organism?
We're going to think about
this simple experiment that's
shown schematically on the top
here in Panel A of this diagram.
We assume we have some
material, and this could be
anything, but let's think about
it in the simplest possible way.
It's some uniform material,
at least initially.
Maybe it's steel,
maybe its rubber,
plastic;
maybe it's some biological
material like a muscle or some
other kind of tissue,
skin, an artery.
Let's just think about rubber
for the beginning,
maybe even a rubber band.
You hang the rubber band from
some solid support that's
unmovable like the ceiling here.
So, we have some way of
affixing this solid material to
the ceiling, and we can measure
some properties of the material,
mechanical properties of the
material.
For example,
it has a length and it has
cross-sectional area.
When we do mechanical
testing we're trying to
understand how that material
behaves when it's exposed to
forces,
when it's exposed to forces it
encounters in the physical
world.
We want to set up an experiment
where we can apply a force
uniformly and measure the result
of that force simply.
The experiment I show here is
just to hang a weight on that
material that's suspended from
the ceiling, that rubber band,
for example.
I hang a weight on it,
and so that weight applies some
force to the material because
gravity is going to pull it down
with some force based on its
mass.
For most materials,
certainly for rubber bands,
if I put them on the--affix
them to the ceiling that way and
attach the weight,
what would happen?
They would lengthen;
they'd get longer because
they're exposed to that weight.
I've applied a force and
I've experienced a deformation.
I've applied a force and the
material has deformed.
I'm going to quantify that,
and I can quantify that fairly
easily because I chose a simple
material that had a constant
cross-sectional area from the
top to the bottom.
I'm going to assume that that
cross-sectional area doesn't
change when it deforms,
but I hang the weight on it and
the length increases.
The length is now L + ΔL.
I can quantify the deformation
here by defining a property
called strain.
The strain is just the change
in length divided by the total
length.
Now, important what length we
use here, and we're going to use
the initial length as the
length.
So, the strain is the change in
length divided by the length in
the unstressed position,
in the unstressed orientation,
unstressed condition,
that's the right word.
Does that make sense?
This is a measure of how
much it deforms and we're going
to define the stress and stress
is just force per unit area.
You can imagine if I hang the
same weight on this material,
if it's as material that has a
large cross-sectional area,
it's very thick,
or it's a material that's very
thin, then its deformation is
going to be different because
that force is going to be
distributed over either a big
area or a small area.
So, the stress is just equal to
the force per area,
and we're going to assume that
we arranged it in some way that
it's uniform over the area.
So the experiment makes sense?
Hang it from the ceiling,
suspended, one end is held
rigid, I put a weight on it,
I watch it deform,
I measure the deformation that
occurs as a result of applying
that stress.
Now, to analyze how this
material behaves under different
stress conditions.
So, I might want to know how
does the muscle of my thigh
behave when it experiences
different kinds of deformations.
What stress builds up when I
stretch it out,
for example,
because I'm interested in the
mechanics of running.
What I want to know is,
"What is the deformation that
occurs in this particular muscle
when I've applied different
forces,
or different stresses to it?"
The way that I would measure
that is by just applying
different forces.
Start with a small force,
add a larger force,
and then measure the
deformation at each of those
conditions.
If I did that I could plot,
on this diagram here,
stress versus strain.
Now, the strain,
remember, just ΔL/L,
the stress just the force
divided by the area.
I would get different points on
this curve and each one would
represent a different experiment
where I added a different force
and eventually I could draw a
line through it.
Now, think back again to
the first example I said,
this simple example,
just a rubber band.
If you did this experiment with
a rubber band,
you hung different forces on
it, what would you see?
As you put more weight on,
the rubber band would stretch
more and more,
and more so the strain would go
up.
In fact, up to a certain amount
of force, if I measured the
strain that results from forces,
I would get a straight line.
I could plot stress versus
strain and I would get a
straight line.
That--a material that behaves
that way is called an elastic
material, that's an elastic
material.
A perfect elastic material,
I could apply those forces,
it would stretch out,
and if I took the forces away
it would go right back up again.
At the end of the experiment of
adding more weight,
then taking the weight off,
the material would be exactly
the same as how it started.
That's an elastic material
that's perfectly reversible,
a perfect elastic material.
Now, I could tell you
everything you need to know
about the elastic properties of
that material by giving you one
number, the slope of this line.
Because once you knew the slope
of this line,
you could draw the curve that
represents all of its stress
strain behavior.
Instead of someone else having
to do this experiment again,
you could just tell them,
"Oh for those rubber bands I
measured the elasticity and the
elasticity or the slope of this
line is some number E."
This letter "E" is called the
elastic modulus or the Young's
modulus and it's a
characteristic of the material.
For this material in this
particular geometry,
that's the elastic modulus.
Someone who knew that would
know how to predict how that
material behaves,
at least under the conditions
in which you did the experiment.
Does that make sense?
Now, if you've studied
physics in the past,
I assume most of you have in
high school, then you've thought
about perfect elastic materials.
What did you call a perfect
elastic material in physics?
Anybody remember studying a
perfect elastic material in
physics?
A spring, that's exactly what a
spring is.
When you talked about springs,
you talked about a spring
constant, which was how to
relate the force to the
elongation.
This is exactly the same thing
but it's sort of described in a
different way because now you're
talking about a real material
that has cross-sectional area,
not an imaginary spring.
When you thought about springs
and spring constants,
you were thinking about this
exact same physical process.
We're just describing it in a
different way now.
In fact, by the end of the
lecture we'll come back to
thinking about springs as a way
of idealizing or describing
materials that have complex
properties.
The spring,
the imaginary object that you
talked about in physics is just
an idealization of real
materials and how they really
behave when forces are applied
to them.
If you continue to add force,
then at some point the
material's not going to behave
perfectly elastically anymore.
You'll see that because it's
not a straight line anymore,
it's not linear.
It still might be elastic but
it's not linearly elastic so you
can't describe it by just the
slope anymore.
At some point,
for any material,
you could enough weight that
it's going to fail.
You could define the stress at
failure, when the material
physically breaks,
or the strain at failure when
it physically doesn't function
as a material anymore;
for the rubber band you add so
much force that it breaks.
There's some weird behavior
that starts to happen when it's
in that mode of starting to
fail,
in that some of the assumptions
that we made don't hold any
longer.
For example,
the assumption that the
cross-sectional area stays the
same.
If you stretch out a rubber
band, if you stretch it so,
so, so much the cross-sectional
area is going to start to cave
in at one point,
not along the whole rubber band
but at some point.
So, it doesn't even behave in
the way that stress continuously
goes up with strain anymore,
and that's because of the way
we've defined it.
The simple experiment makes
sense.
Let's imagine,
then, that we're doing this
experiment where we've got the
material attached to the
ceiling.
It's a rubber band,
still, and we're adding weight
to it.
One way to think about that is
that we're going the point zero,
the totally unstressed
material, and we're adding more
weight.
We're going up towards Point A
here, and so we're moving
towards Point A by adding more
weight to the material and it's
stretching out.
As we're adding more weight,
we're applying more stress;
we're experiencing or observing
more strain.
If you go up to Point A,
I can come back down from Point
A by taking the weights off and
the material will follow exactly
the same path back along the
same stress strain curve.
I could stretch the material,
I could return the material to
its original state,
I could stretch it,
I could return it to its
original state.
That's a reversible elastic
material.
At the beginning it has one
property, you stretch it out,
you let it come back and it's
the same as it was at the
beginning.
That's a perfectly elastic
material.
If you overstretch a
material, that is,
you go instead of Point B you
add so much weight--instead of
Point A you add so much weight
that you go up to Point B.
When you take the weight off it
might now follow the same stress
strain behavior coming back
down.
In this case,
it follows this different
curve, the dotted line here.
Now, what does that mean?
What would you really have
observed when you did this
experiment that ended up being
plotted this way?
I was adding weight,
I was stretching out the
material, and I stretched it so
much that I actually changed the
material.
It can't go back to its
original shape anymore,
but when I take the weight off,
it's permanently deformed.
When I take the weight off it
follows this line back and even
at zero stress it still has some
deformation,
meaning it's longer than it was
when I started.
You've had this experience with
rubber bands or balloons.
If you play with it enough,
you stretch it,
you really stretch it and now
it doesn't go back to its
original shape anymore,
and if you look at the rubber
band it physically looks
different.
There might be a part that's
narrower or the texture of it
looks different because it's
stretched in one direction.
You physically deformed the
material beyond its elastic
limit, and you've created what's
called a plastic deformation.
You've changed the material so
it's not the same anymore.
That's going beyond the elastic
limit, which in this case might
be A, and you've created not
just an elastic deformation but
a plastic deformation.
That material's now forever
changed.
Maybe there some ways that you
can get it back,
but probably not.
It's like--does anybody have a
Slinky?
That's a 60's toy,
you didn't play with Slinky's
but maybe you had.
They used to wire and you could
cut yourself on them and now
they're plastic but they're
these--I need a nod that
somebody else besides me knows
what a Slinky is.
You're supposed to be able to
make it walk down the stairs but
it doesn't ever really work.
If you take a Slinky you can
stretch it out and it'll go
back, stretch it out and it goes
back,
but what if you have your
brother or your sister grab it
and you pull it all the across
the room.
The material gets physically
deformed, it doesn't go back any
longer, that's a plastic
deformation of a Slinky.
Phone cords the same way,
so you have a lot of experience
with this in your real life.
You've used a phone that has a
wire on it, right?
Coil--If we're just talking
about elastic materials,
that means materials that have
the property of elasticity and
they haven't been deformed
beyond their elastic limit,
then I can stretch them,
they'll come back,
stretch them,
come back, and I can do that as
many times as I want and I'll
always get the same material.
You could classify materials
that are elastic into different
properties.
Now, we're not just thinking
about rubber bands but we're
thinking about every material.
Most materials have some
elasticity and over a certain
range of stresses they will
deform elastically.
Steel deforms elastically,
you don't think about it doing
that.
You've got to apply really high
stresses in order for it to
deform but it does deform
elastically.
Wood does under some
conditions, bones do;
all materials do under at least
some range of stress conditions.
Some are going to be what's
called more compliant,
that is they're--at a given
stress, at a given force
application they deform more.
That's a compliant material,
one that's very stretchy or
very elastic.
Or stiff, one that doesn't
deform very much when a stress
is applied, that's a stiffer
material, a less compliant
material.
Or brittle, that is deforms
even less and will break rather
than stretch very much.
You could define different
classes of materials based on
this property of elasticity.
That's one part of what I
wanted you to understand today,
'What's an elastic material,
how would I characterize it,
and what does it mean to be an
elastic material?'
The second thing I want to
think about is viscosity.
Viscosity is a property that we
associate with fluids.
We've talked about viscosity,
we talked about the viscosity
of blood flowing through
arteries,
for example,
and how viscosity contributed
to the resistance of a vessel.
It's in that relationship
between pressure drop and flow.
Well, let's think about another
experiment where we have a fluid
and we want to measure its
viscosity.
That is, we want to measure
what's its resistance to flow of
the fluid?
A way to do that
experiment, and it turns out
that there's a lot more
practical ways than this,
but here's one way to do the
experiment is to take a table
like this one,
a solid surface that's not
going to move and spread the
liquid all over the surface.
Now, let's forget for a minute
about the fact that this table
is only so wide and so fluid's
going to flow off the edges,
and let's assume that I could
put a layer of fluid on here and
it would stay.
Then, I could put another
desktop on top of it,
so what I've created is a space
between two desktops,
one of which is fixed to the
floor so it won't move and the
other which is floating on top
of a layer of fluid.
Does this make sense?
So, now you could imagine
if you could that,
if I had a layer of fluid here
and another desktop sitting on
top,
I could apply a force this way
parallel to the surface and the
thing would move easily.
If it was water it would move
very easily, if it was alcohol
the fluid, it would move very
easily.
If it was molasses it would
move but I'd have to apply more
force in order to move the
desktop on the surface,
but I could do it.
What you're really doing in
that experiment I just described
is the same thing as the
experiment we did when we hung
the rubber band from the top of
the ceiling here,
is that I've applied a force
and I've measured a deformation.
Now, the force and the
deformation are different in
this case because now I'm
applying a force not in tension,
before I was talking about only
applying forces in tension to
create a tension force in the
material.
Now, I'm applying a force in
shear.
I'm trying to move one plate
relative to another plate and
I'm trying to move them across
each other so that's a shear
force.
The deformation is not a
deformation like it increases in
length, the deformation is that
the wall on top moves and it
moves continuously.
Imagine if I start to apply--I
have this setup here,
the desktop is on top of the
layer fluid,
on top of the desktop below,
and I somehow apply a constant
force to that top plate,
that top desktop,
it's going to continue to move
as long as I apply a constant
force it'll move,
it'll move, it'll move,
eventually I'd fall off the
desk here.
What's created is not a strain,
what's created is a velocity.
The top plate is going to move,
and if I apply a constant
force, a constant shearing force
to the top plate I will measure
a velocity.
Does that make sense?
What's really happening in
the fluid here is that within
this fluid, when I apply the
force on the top plate,
the molecules of fluid that are
right next to the top--let me
call it a plate now instead of a
desktop because that's a shorter
word,
that molecules of fluid that
are right next to this top
plate, when I start to move it,
they move along with the top
plate.
Those molecules of fluid
experience some friction with
the top plate,
and when I move the top plate
they move along with.
The molecules of fluid that are
just below that also want to
move along with it,
because there's some friction
between the molecules inside the
liquid.
There's some friction but it's
not perfect friction,
it slips.
Viscosity is a measure of how
slippy the fluid is;
different layers of fluid,
how easily they slide by one
another when they're sheared.
Water, because it has a low
viscosity, compared to molasses,
those layers of water are going
to move easily over one another,
whereas in molasses,
there's more friction between
the layers and so it's harder to
move.
In either case,
what will happen is that when I
apply the force,
the packets of fluid up near
the top are going to move along
with the top plate,
the ones a little below it are
going to move a little slower,
the ones below it are going to
move a little slower than that,
slower than that,
slower than that until the ones
at the very bottom don't move at
all because they're experiencing
friction from the bottom plate.
If I could look microscopically
at what happens when I shear
this top plate over the bottom
plate within the layer of fluid
between,
I've created a velocity
gradient where the fluid is
moving very fast near the top
plate,
slower in the middle,
and not at all at the surface
of the bottom plate.
By doing this I can measure the
force that's required in order
to establish that velocity
gradient.
I'm going to make the same
kind of plot here that I made in
stress versus strain for an
elastic material,
but I'm going to plot different
things.
Instead of stress--tensile
stress I'm going to plot shear
stress, and that is the amount
of force that I've applied on
this wall in order to get it to
move divided by the
cross-sectional area of the
wall.
It's the amount of force I had
to apply in order to set this
thing in constant motion divided
by its cross-sectional area.
What I'm going to plot down
here is the rate of deformation.
Because there is no limit to
the deformation here,
as long as I apply the force
it's going to continue to slide.
I can't measure the strain
because it will continuously
deform, there's no end to it.
What I can measure,
instead, is the maximum
velocity divided by the
thickness, the gap between the
two walls, or the height of the
fluid.
This velocity divided by height
is a measure of the rate of
deformation.
Does that make sense?
Kind of the same thing;
I did an experiment set up a
different way,
applied a force,
measured a deformation.
In this case,
shear stress and rate of
deformation.
What I'd find here is that over
a certain length--over a certain
range of forces,
I would get a straight line.
The slope of that line is this
property called the viscosity.
For fluids that have a high
viscosity like molasses or
honey, I have to apply a lot of
force in order to achieve a
certain velocity.
For fluids that are less
viscous, like water,
I don't need to apply so much
force in order to change that
same velocity,
in order to achieve that same
velocity.
Does this make sense?
Here's another kind of
material, and there are
biological materials that behave
this way, their mechanics are
like this;
blood is one of them.
Blood is a viscous material.
If I put blood between this
here and I did this experiment,
I would see roughly this
behavior.
As I increase the force I
increase the velocity,
and it's linear and I could
measure the viscosity.
Now, it turns out that blood is
a little bit different,
in that it turns out that
unlike water if I apply even the
smallest force the plate's going
to move when it's water between
here.
If it was blood,
it turns out that for small
forces it doesn't move at all,
that I have to apply a certain
amount of force in order to get
it to move.
Why do you think it would
be different for blood than for
water?
What can you imagine that's
different for blood that creates
this situation that at very
small forces it doesn't move at
all,
but it has some yield force or
yield stress that one has to get
over in order to start it in
motion.
What's different about blood
than water?
It's thicker than water,
you know that from the Bible,
isn't that right?
Blood is thicker than water,
I don't even know.
Justin?Student:
Large molecules in red blood
cells.Professor Mark
Saltzman: It has large
molecules and red blood cells,
and has red blood cells at a
fairly high volume fraction,
about 50% is blood cells.
It turns out that to get those
blood cells rolling,
to get them moving out of each
other's way requires a certain
amount of force.
In fact, when blood is
stagnant, even if it's
anti-coagulated,
the blood cells tend to form
structures where they align with
one another,
and so it's hard to get that
moving.
For most of its--for most of
the shear stresses that are
biologically important,
blood behaves as a viscous
liquid, it's about three times
as viscous as water.
So that's viscosity,
so you know about elasticity
and viscosity.
Let's go back now to the
material I talked about at the
beginning and let's assume now
that it's not a perfect elastic
material but it's a material
that is different than that.
Let's do the experiment in a
different way or look at it in a
different way,
where I'm still hanging the
material from the ceiling and
I'm still applying a force to
it,
and I'm asking how it deforms.
Now instead of just looking at
its total deformation I want to
look at how the deformation
changes over time.
Time is an important variable
in most biological processes.
You care not only about how
much deformation I get when I
apply a force,
but you care about how quickly
I achieve that deformation,
and how quickly materials can
physically move when forces are
applied.
If this is a perfect
elastic material like a rubber
band or like the springs you
learned about in physics,
when I apply a force here,
it instantaneously changes its
length.
Deformations are instantaneous;
they take no time at all for a
perfect elastic material.
How much would the deformation
occur?
Well it would depend on the
elasticity, but as soon as I
added that force it's going to
stretch out--bang--to that
length and it's going to stay
there.
You know real materials don't
behave like this but our prefect
elastic material does.
If the material is
viscoelastic,
meaning it has properties of
both elasticity and viscosity
like a muscle,
say, like the fluid that's
inside your eye.
If I apply a force it's going
to exhibit two different
behaviors.
First it's going to elongate
instantaneously just like the
perfect elastic material would
and then it's going to continue
to elongate slowly.
It's going to continue to
elongate.
I've shown that here,
if I look at the length versus
time it's going to
instantaneously elongate to some
extent and then it's going to
slowly keep deforming.
Now, that behavior,
where I apply a force and it
goes initially out to here looks
like elastic material;
the behavior where it
continually starts--continues to
stretch out over time and gets
longer,
and longer, and longer that
looks like a viscous material.
That's how a viscous material
would behave,
I apply a force and it
continuously deforms with some
rate.
This material is behaving like
an elastic solid and like a
viscous liquid,
both.
It's what we call a
viscoelastic material,
and most biological materials
have that property.
They have some viscosity that
is they deform continuously
under stress.
They have some elasticity,
they deform elastically under
stress.
Another way to do this
experiment would be not to hang
a weight and then measure what
deformation occurs,
but to instead do the
experiment as is shown in this
diagram here,
which is stretch the material
out suddenly and then measure
the force that's required to
hold this apart.
For an elastic material,
you'd get the same result.
If you apply a strain,
that is, I just pull this up to
some length, it's going to take
some force to do that.
All the force gets applied
instantaneously and then after
that I just maintain the force
and I hold the material there.
For a viscoelastic material it
behaves differently,
in that its initial response
will be like an elastic solid.
It will--you stretch it out to
its strain and it's going to
take the same force to open it
up, to stretch it out,
to deform it.
Then, the materials going to
relax and start to flow which
would--what you would measure is
that the force required to hold
it at this deformation starts to
drop over time as the material
itself rearranges and deforms in
order to accommodate that strain
that you've put in it.
Does that make sense?
Two ways to do the
experiment, two different ways
of looking at viscoelasticity.
One is you apply a force and
now you can see continuous
deformation, the other is that
you apply a deformation and you
see a change in force required
to hold that deformation over
time.
It turns out that not all
viscoelastic materials exhibit
the same behavior but there's a
range of viscoelastic
properties.
Some viscoelastic materials
behave more like elastic solids,
some behave more like viscous
liquids, and some behave
somewhere in between.
Physicists have figured out
ways, models that they can use
to explain how viscous materials
behave.
You could imagine that this
would be important in biomedical
engineering.
For example,
if I want to understand how the
leg works, then an important
part of how the leg works as a
machine is understanding the
properties of the leg muscles.
How they deform under stress
and how, when stresses are
applied to them,
how that changes their shape.
That's essential for if a
muscle is going to contract and
apply a force to your leg,
then you need to know how the
strain or deformation of that
muscle relates to its ability to
create a force,
to pick up the leg for example,
or to move it.
I'd like some way to
describe that mathematically.
I'd like some way to describe
the stress strain behavior of
complicated biological materials
like muscles.
One way to do that is to build
models based on elements that I
understand.
So, I understand the spring.
I understand the spring and if
it was a perfect--if the muscle
was a perfect elastic material I
could describe all of its
behavior by its spring constant
or its elastic modulus.
I would know everything about
its stress-strain behavior,
but muscles don't behave like
strings because they have some
viscous properties.
What's a simple example of
a viscous material?
Well, I gave you this example
of the plate sliding over the
layer of fluid.
Well, there's another model
that physicist's use to describe
viscous materials and maybe
you've seen this,
it's an element that you don't
really encounter in life.
You encounter things like
springs, but you don't encounter
things like dashpots very often.
That's what this is called;
this is a dashpot.
A dashpot is an idealized
physical model of a viscous
liquid.
One way to imagine it is that
it's a cylinder,
the black cylinder here,
inside of a hollow cylinder.
So, it's a cylinder inside of a
hollow cylinder and there's some
friction between the outside
wall of the black cylinder and
the inside wall of the hollow
cylinder.
There's some well-behaved,
well-known friction between the
inside of the hollow cylinder
and the outside of the inner
cylinder.
Now--then if I apply a
force, apply a force down here
in that direction to this
dashpot what's going to happen?
The inner cylinder is going to
slide over the outer cylinder,
slide through the outer
cylinder.
For a constant force,
since this is a
well-behaved--the friction
between here is well-known and
well-behaved,
it's going to just slide with a
uniform velocity the inner
cylinder over the outer
cylinder.
Does that make sense?
So, this dashpot is an
idealized physical model for how
a viscous liquid behaves.
I apply a force and it
continuously deforms.
Now, it's better as a thought
experiment than a real
experiment because you can
imagine making things that
behave like real springs.
Real dashpots would be hard to
make.
Why?
Because eventually no matter
how long your outer cylinder
was, you'd eventually come out
of it.
A real dashpot,
if it's going to deform for a
long time, would have to be
infinitely long as well,
so it's better as a thought
experiment than a real thing to
build but you get the thought
experiment,
right?
I have a spring here,
how will it behave when I force
on it?
It's going to deform
instantaneously to a certain
length.
The length will depend on the
force.
The dashpot,
I apply a force to it,
how will it behave?
It's going to slowly deform
over time, continuously with a
constant rate but it will never
stop deforming.
What would happen if I put a
spring and a dashpot together
like this?
That is, I have a solid wall
here, I first attach a spring,
and I attach a dashpot to the
spring, and now I apply a force.
Well, this spring-dashpot
combination is going to have
elastic properties,
it's going to have viscous
properties,
but it's going to behave in a
certain way.
When I apply the force,
the force is going to be
applied over the whole structure
at once.
The spring is going to fully
experience that force and it's
going to stretch out.
Then, the dashpot is also going
to experience that force and
it's slowly going to deform.
What I would observe
experimentally,
if I could build this spring
dashpot combination,
is I'd see an initial
deformation and then continuous
deformation after that.
This is an example of one kind
of viscoelastic behavior.
If I took my muscle,
and I did measurements on it,
and I found experimentally that
it behaved like this,
then I would say,
'Oh I can describe how the
muscle behaves by this simple
thought experiment,
this simple mathematical
construct of a spring and a
dashpot connected together.'
Does that make sense?
Well that's not the only
way that you could create a
viscous--that you could create
an imaginary viscoelastic
material.
I could also attach the spring
and the dashpot in series,
that is, attach both the spring
and the dashpot to the wall,
have a little strut connecting
them, and then apply the force
that way.
How would this material behave?
It would behave differently
because when the force is
applied the spring,
would like to stretch out but
it can't.
It can't because it's
constrained by the dashpot which
only deforms slowly.
The spring would like to
deform, would like to take all
of the force and deform,
but it can't because the
dashpot physically takes time to
move.
It can only deform at some rate.
In the initial period the
dashpot is taking all of the
force and what you would see
initially is slow deformation.
Now, while the dashpot would
like to keep deforming forever,
this thing can't because the
spring has a limit to how much
it can stretch.
When you get up to the elastic
limit of the spring,
or the elasticity of the
spring, the spring is going to
be taking all of the force.
The dashpot,
then, will have no force on it,
and it will stop deforming.
A viscoelastic material
that behaved like a spring and a
dashpot in series would have
this behavior.
It would not have any initial
deformation.
It would deform slowly at first
and then it would reach some
maximum deformation like an
elastic solid,
but it would be evolving over
time.
Does this make sense?
Now, these are two simple
models of materials that have
viscous and elastic properties.
I could measure real materials
and I could see,
'Well, do they act more like
this, do they act more like
this?'
I could use these thought
constructs in order to describe
those materials.
I could learn about how the
materials behave under unusual
conditions that way,
I could start to predict how
they behave.
It turns out that most real
viscoelastic materials don't
obey either this model or this
model, but you can build more
complex ones.
You could imagine having a
spring and dashpot on this side
and just a dashpot over here,
or you could imagine having
three elements in a series.
You could imagine all sorts of
different ways of putting
viscous elements and elastic
elements together to define an
imaginary material.
You could then predict how that
imaginary material is going to
behave and you could see how
close it is to real materials.
What I want you to remember
from this is a couple of
different things.
One, we talked about elasticity
at the beginning,
how do purely elastic materials
behave, you know that.
How do purely viscous materials
behave?
You understand that.
Real materials,
real biological materials
have--are viscoelastic.
They have both elastic and
viscous property,
but that doesn't mean just one
thing.
That can mean a whole range of
behaviors.
It's possible in some cases to
define that whole range of
behaviors by building simple
thought experiments or simple
models like these spring-dashpot
combinations.
In general, the
viscoelastic--real viscoelastic
materials we see are more
complex than any of the--we have
more complex behaviors than any
of the idealized models we put
together,
although sometimes they come
very close.
Questions?
If you looked for the
homework assignment over the
weekend, and then you look at it
today, or yesterday,
you will have noticed that it
changed.
It became simpler.
I decided that first I had a
homework assignment that had two
parts.
The first part of it was to
write an introductory paragraph
for your paper and an outline
for the rest and turn it in.
Then, there was some problems
related to the material for this
week from Chapter 10.
What I decided to do instead
was ask you just to focus on
your papers this week,
and just turn in that
introductory paragraph and the
outline.
That's all the homework for
this week, and then we'll put
off the homework assignments on
this topic,
and what we'll talk about
Thursday that won't be due until
next Thursday.
I'd like for you to really
focus on your research papers
this week.
We'll come back and we'll do
the homework set next week.
Then, the week after that there
won't be any homework except
just to finish your research
papers and that will be the week
that it's due.
I just wanted you to keep that
in mind, because I know that
timing and balancing all of your
responsibilities to different
courses is critical at this time
of the year.
Questions about that or about
what I talked about at the
beginning: instructions for the
paper, peer-reviewing?
Good, see you on Thursday.